[Music]
2018 offered a huge range of Awesome
diverse films in just about every genre
but which are at the top of their class
these are the very best films 2018 has
to offer John Krasinski best known for
his role as Jim Halpert on the office
probably isn't a name that comes to mind
when thinking about the horror genre I
ate a tuna sandwich on my first day so
Andy started calling me a big tuna I
don't think any of them actually know my
real name but after cutting his
directorial teeth on TV and a couple of
well-received low-budget features
present scheme made the leap from the
world of comedy to the realm of fright
flicks with a quiet place grazinsky
stars along with his wife Emily Blunt in
the tale of a couple plagues by
mysterious creatures who hunt by sound
forcing them into a tense and silent
existence Rolling Stones Peter Travers
called it an instant horror classic
citing Blunt as a highlight by calling
her in a class by herself taking a near
silent role in building a tour de force
of expressive emotion the Toronto Sun's
Liz Braun agreed
calling a quiet place a terrific movie
beautifully made and carried along by
strong performances and skillful
storytelling it'll scare the hell out of
YouTube in a year that shaped up to be a
great one for fans of horror a quiet
place stands atop the critical heap
after 10 years Marvel Studios isn't
surprising anyone with the high quality
of its films with director Ryan Coogler
and star chadwick boseman on board black
panther was naturally another winner the
film managed to surpass even the highest
of expectations surpassing 1.3 billion
dollars at the worldwide box office
making it the highest grossing solo
superhero movie of all time the movie
appeals to more diverse audiences than
standard superhero fare at Black Panther
was simply astonishingly good
interesting many critics have were
claimed it to be on a totally different
level from the rest of the MCU exploring
themes of alienation and loss more
effectively than a comic book film has
any right to special credit goes to
Michael B Jordans conflicted villain
Erik kill monger Stevens who's been
cited as the emcee used best villain
ever thanks largely to the actors
towering performance don't trip I'm
going to take it off your hands for you
these items aren't for sale how do you
think your ancestors got these you think
they paid a fair price / film summed it
up the best run don't walk to the
theater to see Black Panther this is not
hyperbole saying it's just good is under
selling it is perhaps the best film of
2018 even the eye-popping box-office
success of Black Panther was only a
warm-up act for Avengers infinity war
would shatter too many records the list
here part one of the culmination of
Marvel's three phase mega art brought
together nearly every hero introduced in
the MCU thus far and fans responded by
putting up tremendous box office numbers
sure Infinity Ward didn't earn the
widespread critical adoration enjoyed by
Black Panther but positive reviews
recognized it as a gigantic feat of
storytelling delivering meaningful arcs
for characters we've come to know and
love notably its villain Josh Brolin's
Thanos moved some critics to declare the
mad Titan as one of the MCS most
effective villains ever you planet was
on the brink of collapse I'm the one who
stopped at the film's amazingly dark
cliffhanger ending caused some reviewers
to call infinity warp half a movie but
perhaps their tune will change when
Avengers 4 debuts in 2019 it's no
surprise here that Marvel Studios landed
their 20th straight film to debut at
number one with a lively and
entertaining ant-man in the wasp
audiences needed a bit of a palate
cleanser after Thanos this big snap and
returning director Peyton Reed gave them
one a worthy sequel to 2015 ant-man this
follow-up is even more assured and
perhaps even funnier than the original
you remember that beloved commercial
[Music]
filmfare calm went so far as to call it
quote the funniest Marvel film you'll
see which is high praise considering
that Thor Ragnarok was released less
than a year prior the films loose
playful tone and competently staged
action pieces made even more novel use
of the hero size changing technology
than the original and the film's
reasonably low stakes compared to
infinity war make it a great light break
from the MC use recent trend toward
all-out destruction but if you're still
traumatized from infinity war you may
want to skip ant-man in the wasp
post-credit scene fans of Ryan Reynolds
Merc with a mouth eagerly awaited the
follow-up to 2016 s ridiculously popular
r-rated hit Deadpool and Reynolds along
with incoming director david leitch
didn't disappoint fans of the original
knew they could expect insane action and
over-the-top vulgarity but most weren't
ready for the surprising amount of
character building and emotion in the
sequel plus as promised they introduced
cable on this one wire gushed over the
performances of the entire cast noting
that Deadpool's assembly of the mutant
superhero team x-force gives Deadpool to
a much stronger narrative arc and
emotional payoff than its predecessor
they also praised the ending calling it
surprisingly part felt this sequel
actually set out to be a movie not just
the series of jokes stuck to a MacGuffin
it's the rare sequel that might just
surpass its beloved predecessor and some
critics called its post-credit scene the
best one ever which is really saying
something
picking up literally seconds after the
2004 original Incredibles 2 deals with
the destructive consequences of
superhero battles and how the PAR family
survives in a rapidly changing world but
even in this era of superhero movie box
office dominance Incredibles 2 is unique
and it still manages to stand
shoulder-to-shoulder with everything
Marvel and DC have to offer and one of
the many glowing reviews for the film
Calvin Wilson of the st. Louis
post-dispatch called it one of the most
entertaining films of the year and one
of the smartest it sets a standard that
few superhero flicks animated or
live-action can match in a year
typically stuffed to the brim with
high-profile superhero adventures
Incredibles 2 proves marvel
Studios aren't the only ones who know
how to score a critical hit in the genre
for over two decades Tom Cruise has put
himself in mortal danger for the
surprisingly resilient mission
impossible franchise which has failed to
lose speed
despite its star's advancing age now in
his 50s Cruz continues to insist on
doing every stunt that it's physically
possible for him to do honestly
audiences don't go to a Mission
Impossible film for character beats or
high drama they come for the action and
Mission Impossible fallout delivered in
spades director Christopher McQuarrie
surehand behind the camera plus Cruz's
dedication to the role of eternally
put-upon IMF agent Ethan Hunt resulted
in a crackerjack pitcher which pulled
down some of the best reviews of the
entire series as impossible as it may
seem this venerable action franchise and
its star just seem to be getting better
with age or as succinctly put by the
detroit news 'as adam graham bless this
franchise were truly not worthy crazy
rich Asians featuring constants whoo as
a native New Yorker who accompanies her
boyfriend to a wedding in Singapore
became a surprising critical smash and a
cultural phenomenon as the only romantic
comedy in recent memory to feature a
nearly all Asian cast reviewer Randy
Jones encapsulated the positive
consensus and concluding his review
crazy rich Asians takes familiar tropes
and revitalizes them and its entire
genre with a great cast amazing
direction and powerful writing like
Black Panther before it's crazy rich
Asians constitutes a clear message The
Hollywood execs that heartfelt
well-executed stories featuring people
of color can not only cross cultural
boundaries but smash them and earn huge
box office in the process a classic
Hollywood story that's been revisited no
fewer than three times since the 1937
original a star is born got new life in
2018 with a lovingly crafted retelling
that may prove to not only be the finest
version of the story put to film but one
of the greatest remakes of all time
directed by and starring Bradley Cooper
the film tells the story of
up-and-coming singer Ally played by Lady
gaga who falls in love with an
established musician and begins her
ascent to stardom even as the career of
her mentor and lover begins to decline
cooper displays some true directorial
skills adam Epstein of quartz called his
direction quotes instinctive and
remarkably orchestrated enhancing his
own spot-on performance while taking
full advantage of
smouldering star power - nobody
surprised she absolutely crushes it in
her first big-screen leading role with
piles of notices singling out the
realistic chemistry between the two
leads and Gaga's powerful and winning
screen presence expect Oscar nominations
striking actress Anya Taylor joy has
been busy carving out a niche for
herself as a modern-day scream queen
with highly visible roles and critically
acclaimed fright flicks - which and
split in just the last few years
first-time writer director Corey Finley
was lucky enough to secure her for his
debut feature the black comedy thriller
thoroughbreds and with the help of his
clockwork script and tension generating
direction he was able to score a winner
on his first outing the plot follows
reuniting friends lily and Amanda as
they schemed to murder the former
stepfather critics agree that Finley
shows the kind of self-assuredness and
confidence in his vision that normally
alludes freshmen filmmakers Christy
Lemire praised the film as classically
Hitchcockian in its smoldering homicidal
tendencies yet bracing the current other
reviews singled out Finley's masterful
balance of humour and darkness it seems
that he nailed it and also that we might
have a major new talent on our hands
loved Simon was destined for praise for
one simple reason it's the first major
studio Hollywood film to focus on a gay
teen romance which is a groundbreaking
endeavor in and of itself
fortunately director Greg Berlanti
delivered a film that's notable for far
more than just that reason
it's a funny disarmingly sweet rom-com
that some critics are comparing to the
best work of John Hughes working from a
2015 young adult novel titled Simon vs.
the homo sapiens agenda' the script is
populated with strongly drawn characters
all with feelings and motivations
familiar to anyone Nick Robinson was
singled out for praise in the lead role
among a strong cast which included
Jennifer Garner Josh Duhamel and
Alexandra Shipp critic Sheila O'Malley
called the film quotes a radically
inclusive act which was a common theme
throughout most of the glowing reviews
then of geeks Delia Harrington
proclaimed it a rare uplifting romantic
AF LGBTQ movie to be prized with a
modern soundtrack and a diverse cast
love Simon is the kind of movie many
people wish they had growing up the
films in the transformer series have
produced consistently diminishing
returns both critically and at the box
office and you could be forgiven for
expecting bumblebee to offer more of the
same
but with director Travis Knight taking
over from Michael Bay and working from a
smart 80 set script a funny thing
happened bumblebee debuted two stellar
reviews with near universal praise for
its smaller more personal story and
throwback vibe meanwhile lead Hailee
Steinfeld was singled out for her
heartfelt nuanced performance Shirley
the first time those words have been
applied to a Transformers movie for
proof of that see Exhibit A simply put
bumblebee served up what the series had
thus far struggled to provide heart
wonder and fun
[Music]
Sony animations Spider Man into the
spider verse skipped the traditional
Peter Parker focused Spidey story in
favor of fan favorite Miles Morales
based loosely on the spider verse comics
event in which multiple spider people
from different universes must band
together to take on a common threat the
film leaned into the idea that anybody
could be behind the mask and followed
through with its wildly eclectic
collection of Spider characters hey guys
it's Gwen actually oh you know her very
cool in addition to its spot-on
characterizations and story the flick
through tons of praise for its insanely
innovative animation style rendered to
look as if it were leaping right off the
comics page
some critics went so far as to call it
the best spider-man film ever made with
others suggesting it should be a shoo-in
for an Academy Award in the animation
category an unmitigated triumph for Sony
into the spider-verse opened up whole
new avenues of storytelling for Spidey
and garnered wider acclaim than nearly
any wide release of 2018 check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]